todas las cosas del agua que se pueda
recoger para riego es buena sé de donde
sea y siempre y cuando sea de un buen
uso de riego que sea analizada que sea
agua que se pueda que se pueda regar que
no haya ningún prejuicio para la salud
No que no sea mala
[Música]
lo que intentamos desde la región de
murcia es que cada gota de agua residual
darle una segunda vida aparte de verter
la un cauce o al mar una vez depurada
intentamos que vuelva al sistema para
poderse reutilizada en agricultura
[Música]
es un modelo que la verdad es muy
pionero llevan muchos años de
experiencia desde el año 2000
regenerando y reutilizando agua con lo
cual somos años de experiencia y muchas
delegaciones de países extranjeros
vienen a visitarnos pero tanto de Europa
como de latinoamérica hace poco tuvimos
la visita también de personas de
técnicos del Líbano y de Palestina otras
veces vienen de Argentina o Bolivia e
incluso también Vienen de Alemania
Holanda y Francia
[Música]